Ben tcik 9 sınıf öğrencilerim coğrafi
kar okula YouTube'un en büyük coğrafi
kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz zedu
öğretmenleri olarak yaptığımız okula
destek kampımız devam ediyor bugün
geldik coğrafya kısmının 16 en önemli
gününe bugün gençler Belki de 9 sınıf
boyunca göreceğiniz en önemli video bu
video Çünkü bu videoda iklim türlerini
öğreneceğiz iklim türleri bizim için o
kadar fazla önemlidir ki iklim türlerini
bildiğinde bitkiye dünyada bitkiler
hakkında dünyadaki topraklar hakkında
dünyadaki birçok şey hakkında yorum
yapabiliyoruz Biz aslında iklim türleri
bizim temelimiz oluşturan temel atmamızı
sağlayan en önemli sütunlardan bir
tanesidir sana ne diyorum her zaman önce
dünya haritaları kampını öğreneceksin
öyle başlayacaksın 9 sınıfa ve lise
hayatına Çünkü dünya haritaları kampını
başladığında bitirdiğinde önce çölleri
öğretiyorum sana orada sonra dağların
yerlerini falan gösteriyorum sonra
iklime geçiyoruz Bu iç bize müthiş bir
temel Atıyor işte bu derste iklim
türlerini göreceğiz Sakın ha bu derse
atlamak yok Bu dersle alakalı soru çözüm
videosu gelecek bu dersten sonra o soru
çözüm videosunu da deli gibi
çalışacaksın çözeceksin bu konuyu
tamamlarsan lise hayatın boyunca çok
rahat edeceksin o yüzden dikkatli
dinliyorsun Ben kalemimi aldım hazırım
Sen de beğen tuşuna basıp abone olarak
Hazırlandı sanki biliyorum sen vefalı
öğrencisin abone olmuşsundur öyle hain
Kostak gibi abone olmadan izleme
yapmıyorsun diyoruz ve o zaman ne
diyoruz Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma zedu ile eğitim her
yerde gençler bakın bugünkü konumuz
iklim türleri ama Milli Eğitim
bakanlığı'nı eleştirdiğim bir nokta var
burada yeni müfredatı Ben hep ne dedim
size yeni müfredat çok güzel yeni
müfredat harika Gerçekten de beğeniyorum
ve bugüne kadar da öyle çok fazla
eleştirmede doğru yaptılar dedim ama çok
büyük bir hata yapmışlar Milli Eğitimin
kitabında iklim türlerini anlatmamış
iklim türleriyle alakalı doğru düzgün
bilgi vermemişler öle hop üstünden geçip
gitmişler ya Böyle bir şey olabilir mi
iklim türleri nedir biliyor musunuz
gençler yemek yapıyorsunuz kuru fasulye
yapacaksınız o Kuru fasulyeyi böyle su
koysanız ve Fasulyeleri döksen ne olur
fasulye haşlanır değil mi tabağa
koyduğunuzda yemek gibi olur mu olmaz ha
iklim türleri yoksa bir yemekte bir
konuda işte böyle olur yemeğiniz iklim
türleri bu yemeğin salçası soğanı
yağıdır salçasını soğan yağını
koyacaksın kavuracak öyle yemek olacak o
yüzden bu iklim türü olmazsa coğrafya
olmaz bu iklim türlerini şimdi çok güzel
bir şekilde anlatacağım öğreteceğim sana
Bu videoda çok dikkatli dinliyorsun
bakın Biz bir şeyler öğrendik sizinle
Gençler bu iklim türlerine gelene kadar
Bayağı da zamanımızı aldı ya Bayağı da
zorladı bizi açıkçası neydi Bunlar bakın
sıcaklık basınç rüzgarlar nem ve yağış
biz bunları niye öğrendik biliyor
musunuz bunlar toplandığında bir yerde
bir yerde bir yere bakıyoruz biz tamam
mı Bu yerin sıcaklığını ölçüyoruz
yağışını ölçüyoruz bunları not alıyoruz
nemini rüzgarını ölçüyoruz ve bunların
bir benzer olduğu alanların
ortalamalarını alıyoruz ha diyoruz bak
burada böyle ortalama gösteriyorlar
bütün bu değerler ve bunlar benzer İşte
o benzerlikler sonucunda iklimler ortaya
çıkıyor Karadeniz iklimi dediğimiz şey
aslında bir yağışının sıcaklığının
neminin benzer u olduğu bir ortam bu
benzer olunca buna bir isim veriyoruz
Diyoruz ki Karadeniz iklimi bu benzer
oluyor buna bir isim veriyoruz a Burası
Akdeniz iklimi benzer oluyor Diyoruz ki
Ekvatoral iklim İşte bunların benzer
olduğu yerler bize iklimleri Yani
dünyada görülen makr klima iklimleri
ortaya çıkartıyor bakın kelimeye bakın
Makro klima klima iklima demiştik değil
mi iklima iklim Tamam Makro iklim Makro
büyük iklimler işte büyük iklimler böyle
çıkıyor ortaya bakın Bunlar büyük
iklimler dünyada görülen büyük
iklimlerin haritası dur oraya geleceğiz
Oraya gelmeden önce şöyle bir de bir de
mikroklima var a mikro Makro büyük
iklimler mikro küçük iklimler gençler
Bunlar Makro klima iklimlerin İçlerinde
bir yerlerde mesela dağlarla çevrili
oluyor Iğdır bizim ülkemizde Iğdır var
mesela çevresi dağlarla çevrili böyle
bir çukur gibi bir yer oranın sıcaklık
değeri içinde bulunduğu büyük iklimi
yansıtmıyor içinde bulunduğu büyük iklim
sert soğuk geçerken orası Oradan daha
sıcak geçiyor oraya daha böyle küçük
Mikro bir iklim oluşuyor orada mikr
klima iklim diyoruz biz de ona mikr
klima iklim tanımı da bu Bir de gençler
geçiş iklimleri var geçiş iklimi de
göreceğiz Türkiye'de örnekler ya şimdi
Akdeniz'den Karadeniz iklimine geçeceğiz
mesela İstanbul ya böyle hem Akdeniz Hem
Karadeniz böyle karışık bir iklime sahip
geçiş iklimi Çünkü orası böyle geçiş
iklimler imizin olduğu yerler de var
Bunları Şimdi göreceğiz Merak etmeyin
ama bunları görmeden önce Hani az önce
size dedim ya yağ sıcaklık sıcaklık bir
araya geliyor yağış bir araya geliyor ve
ortaya iklimler çıkıyor bu iklimleri Biz
tarif ederken böyle sıcaklık ve yağış
grafikleriyle tarif ediyoruz çünkü bakın
Aslında şunlar yağışları gösteriyor işte
şunlar da sıcaklığı bu sıcaklık ve yağış
bir araya gelip iklimi oluşturuyor bu
sıcaklık ve yağışın bir araya gelip
oluşturduğu iklimin de bu sıcaklık ve
yağışını gösteren bir grafik çıkıyor
ortaya bu grafik okuma becerisi bizim
için çok değerli bu grafikleri
okuyabiliyorsan birçok soruyu
yapabiliyorsun üniversite sınavında da
genelde üzerinde durdukları budur grafik
okuma becerisi çıkar karşımıza Peki
hocam şöyle bir grafik karşıma
çıktığında Ben bunu nasıl okuyacağım
bakın gençler grafiğimiz şöyle bir
lejantı vardır hatırlayın haritaları
okurken Lejant vardı yani bize bu
grafikte bazı şeyleri gösteriyor diyor
ki mavi olanlar yağıştan Ben Şuradaki
Maviler bana neyi gösteriyormuş yağışı
gösteriyormuş Şuradaki kırmızı çizgiler
de diyor sıcaklıktır diyor Tamam he
Şuradaki kırmızı çiz çizgi sıcaklığı
gösteriyormuş sonra grafiğin bir sol
tarafı bir de sağ tarafı var dikkat edin
sol taraf bakın milimetre milimetre
yağış Ha demek ki ben mesela sana Mart
ayının ya da martı değil de ekim ayını
uzaktakini söyleyeyim kafan karışsın
Ekim ayının yağış miktarını söyle bana
desem yağış miktarını O zaman şunu
yaparsın yağış miktarı ne mavi olan
gelirsin ekimi bulursun yağış miktarı
mavi olanı bulursun Nereye gelmiş Şu
çizgiye gelmiş peki ben yağış miktarını
ne tarafa bakacağım yağış miktarı sol
taraf o zaman gelirsin bunu bu tarafa
getir a Tamam hocam 50 mm o zaman Ekim
ayının yağış miktarı 50 mm dersin Tamam
bu grafiği okumayı öğren sınavda bu
çıkacak karşına bu yağışını okuma
yöntemimiz Peki Ekim ayının sıcaklığını
oku dersem sana ne yaparsın o zaman ekim
ayını yine bulursun bu sefer bak maviye
bakmazsın bu sefer sıcaklık hocam
kırmızı çizgi o zaman Ekim ayının
sıcaklığını şöyle bir çıkartırsın
kırmızı çizgiyi bulursun ha hocam şurası
Ekim ayının sıcaklığı Peki onu bu tarafa
mı getireceğim Hayır bu taraftaki
soldaki yağıştan bu sefer bunu şöyle
küçülte bu sefer bunu sıcaklık kısmına
sağ tarafa getireceğim getiriyorum bakın
şurada kırmızıyı bu tarafa getirdim 15
dereceymiş hocam Ekim ayının yağışı
yağışı 50 mm hocam sıcaklığı Sıcaklığı
da 15 sant dereceymiş nasıl okuduğumuzu
anladın mı bu ekim ayı için mesela Peki
hocam bu alt tak akiler neyi ifade
ediyor bakın İşte bunlar ayları Ekim
ayına gitmemin nedeni oydu bakın ocak
şubat mart nisan mayıs haziran temmuz
ağustos eylül ekim kasım aralık 12 ayı
ifade ediyor bu ve buraya bazen Ocak
Şubat yazmaz da 1 2 3 4 5 yazar o zaman
da sen 1ci ay 2ci ay 3C ay diye bakarsın
tamam başka bu grafikte Neyi
okuyabilirim en yüksek sıcaklığın olduğu
ayı bulabilirim değil mi A en yüksek
sıcaklık şuraya şurada Neymiş bu Temmuz
ağustosa güzel en düşük sıcaklık
bakıyorum A bak şurada Ocak ayındayım
Tamam peki
e kuraklığı bulabilir miyim kuraklık ne
demek biliyor musun sıcaklığın en fazla
olduğu yağışın en az olduğu bakın şuraya
bakar mısınız şurada bir kuraklık
yaşanıyor neden e burada sıcaklık çok
yüksek ama yağış az Ha demek ki Sıcaklık
fazla topraktaki su buharlaşıp gidecek
kuraklık olacak su yok demek ki
kuraklığın yaşandığı Ay burası yağmurun
en fazla olduğu mevsim bak mevsim dedim
bu sefer buradan mevsimleri de
bulabilirsin nedir mart nisan mayıs
hocam burası ilkbahar Mevsimi değil mi
haziran temmuz ağustos yaz mevsimi
mevsimleri de buldum Eylül Ekim Kasım
sonbahar mevsimi Ama bakın bir şey var
kış mevsiminin aralık ayı 12 ay olduğu
için grafiğin sonuna kayıyor sonra Ocak
Şubat diye diğer grafiğin başından
başlıyor dikkat edin Aslında aralıkla
Şuradaki ile buradakiler aynı Ay kış
mevsiminin ayı unutmayın aralık son
kısma kayıyor Ocak Şubat başa kayıyor
Aslında burası kış mevsim Anlaştık mı bu
grafiği de böyle yorumladık başka nasıl
Yorum yapabilirsiniz buranın yıllık
yağış miktarını bulabiliriz Bir önceki
şeyde öğretmişti derste sana yıllık
yağış miktarı bak aylık değil aylığını
Az önce bulduk ekimi bulduk az önce
Şimdi bize yıllık soruyor yıllık sorarsa
O zaman ben bunları toplarım 100 işte
175 225 kafadan 275 300 bakın ne
yapıyorum bunların hepsini toplarsam
yıllık yağış miktarını da bulabilirim
Tamam ya da yıllık sıcaklık ortalaması
da bulabilirim ne demek hocam yıllık
sıcaklık ortalaması bir ayın sıcaklık
ortalamasını buldum az önce o zaman
yıllığını da bulurum yıllık sıcaklık
ortalaması yani şu mesela Ocak ayında 5
derece diyelim işte Şubat ayında 5
derece diğer ay 10 derece sonra 15
derece bunları toplasam 12 tane
sıcaklığı toplasam ve bunu 12 ay
yaşıyoruz ya 12 aya bölsem ne olur o
zaman ortalama sıcaklığı bulurum değil
mi yıllık ortalama Sıcaklığı da
bulabiliyorum Demek ki grafikten
Anlaştık mı peki
çok güzel bakın üniversite sınavında da
çıkmış bir soruydu kışlar kar yağışlı mı
geçer Şu an şu grafikte Mesela bakıyorum
gençler şurası 0 derece bakın şurası
sıcaklık ya şurası 0 derece Eğer
Şuradaki sıcaklık ıın altına düşseydi o
zaman şurada gerçekleşen yağmur kar
şeklinde düşüyor derdik ama şu an bakın
kış mevsimi kar yağmayan bir yer burası
neden sıcaklık 0 derecenin altına
düşmemiş Anlaştık mı buradaki mantığı
yağışlar genel olarak tabii Tabii ki
yoksa 30 günde bir gün öyle hafiften bir
kar atmış değil genel olarak yağışlar
yağışlar genel olarak Yağmur şeklindedir
derim Çünkü sıcaklık 0 derecenin üstünde
öğrenmiş öğretmişti sana bir önceki
derste sıcaklık 0 derecenin altına
düşerse He yağışlar kar şeklindedir
genel olarak diyebiliriz O zaman bu
mantığı da unutma bu grafik Okumayı da
öğrettim şimdi sana şimdi gelelim baş
kısmımı iklimlere gençler Şimdi gelelim
dünyadaki iklim türlerine bütün o
ortalamalara göre oluşan Makro iklimler
var sıcak iklimler ılıman iklimler soğuk
iklimler şimdi MEB kitabında sadece bunu
böyle anlatmış sıcak iklimler bunlardır
soğuk iklimler sadece isimlerini vermiş
ılıman iklimler de bunlardır demiş ama
bunların özelliklerini bilmemiz lazım
Nasıl yapacağız şimdi bizim dünya
haritaları kampımız bizim temel kampımız
demiştim sana değil mi bu bizim dünya
haritaları kampımız Bunun için de
iklimleri sana öğrettiğim bir yer var ve
iklimleri pekiştirdiğini de yaptığımız
bir yer var şurası bunu git çalış desem
sana çalışmayacaksın biliyorum O yüzden
şu an iklimleri anlatırken oradaki o
videoyu getirip buraya koyacağım
iklimleri öğreneceksin sonra geleceksin
bu videodan devam edeceğiz Tamam Milli
Eğitimin müfredatına koymamış oradaki
iklim anlatımlarını O yüzden mecbur
oradan alıp koyacağım iklimi
öğreniyorsun sonra Dersimize devam
ediyoruz İlk olarak Akdeniz ikliminden
başlayacağız bana göre en önemlisi Şu an
için Akdeniz iklimi haline geldi
yıllardır artık sorulmuyor artık zamanı
geliyor dikkat etmen gerekiyor Akdeniz
iklimi dediğimizde hemen kodlamam
geliyor aklımıza ara sınıflarda 9da 10
sınıfta 9 sınıfta izlediysen beni o
kodlamayı sana yapmışımdır Ne diyordum
karstik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalı kış
cephe karsik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalık
kış cephe karsik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki
Çalık kış cephe bunu böyle Tekrar Et
gençler çok işinize yarayacak geçen sene
2024'te bir soru yaptırdı bu kodlama ona
göre kasti Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalık
kış cephe ne demek Akdeniz ikliminin
bulunduğu yerde bizim bölgemizde Gençler
bu yani Türkiye'de karstik arazi var
karstik arazi Akdeniz iklimi bulunduğu
yerde karstik Akdeniz kızılçam kızılçam
ağaçları vardır Kızıl Çamlar kesilince
makiler ortaya çıkar karstik Akdeniz
kızılçam Maki Çalı Çalı Çalı makiler bir
çalıdır karsik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki
Çalı kış cephe Akdeniz iklimi kışın
yağışını alır ve bu cephe şeklindedir
karsik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalı kış
Tepe karsik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalık
kış cephe karsik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki
Çalık kış cephe Akdeniz kızılçam Maki
Çalık kış cephe sadece bir tane kelime
söyleyerek kelimeler dizisi söyleyerek
bütün Akdeniz ikliminin özelliklerini
öğrenmiş olduk bakın karstik ha saçma
gelebilir Size iki kere ü kere tekrar
ettikten sonra aklınıza gelecek
unutmayın geçen sene sınav sorusu yapt
karsik Deniz kızılçam Maki Çalı kış
cephe soruyu çözerken zihninde böyle
Yunus hocanın sesi gelecek karsik
Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalık kış cephe
Tamam bunu öğrendik gençler şu cephesel
yağışların diğer ismini oraya Not alır
mısınız frontal yağış frontal kodlaması
da şu frontal fırını fırından geliyor
cephesel yağış ne demek biliyor musunuz
Bir sıcak cephe var Bir de soğuk cephe
var E cephe diyor Savaş askerleri gibi
düşünün Bir sıcak bir soğuk sıcak ve
soğuk cephenin karşılaştığı yerlerde
oluşan yağış bu cephesel kodlaması
frontal yabancı ismi frontal nasıl
kodlayın frontal fırın fırının içi sıcak
dışı soğuk ikisi nasıl karşılaştılar
sıcak soğuğun karşılaştığı yer frontal
Demek ki neymiş cephesel demiş cephesel
yağışı nerede gördük Akdeniz ikliminin
görüldüğü yerde gençler Akdeniz iklimi
30 40 enlemlerde görünüyor bunu çok
fazla böyle bilmene gerek yok 30'da mı
40'ta mı 50'de mi diye ama bunu da
söylemiş olayım Şimdi geldik bu dersin
asıl önemli olan kısmına Akdeniz
ikliminin harita çalışmasına Çünkü biz
Akdeniz iklimi ile alakalı bilgileri
zaten iklim konusunda çok ayrıntılı bir
şekilde göreceğiz burada harita
çalışması yapıyoruz Akdeniz iklimi
denildiğinde hemen aklımıza ne geliyor
Bizim Akdeniz geliyor o zaman gelip
akdeniz'i bulacaksın bak akdeniz'i
buldum gördün mü biraz daha kalınlaştır
şunu şöyle bak akdeniz'i buldum
akdeniz'i bulduktan sonra karşı tarafa
bir çizgi çiziyorsun Bak şöyle çizdim
Şurayı işaretledim gördük mü sonra
Afrika'nın en kuzeyinde
iizi şöyle duruyorum alışmışım böyle
durmaya hep boynumuz belimiz bükük
durmaya alışmışız bir türlü dik
duramıyorum Afrika'nın en kuzeyinden en
güneyine ineceğiz bu sefer bak
Afrika'nın en kuzeyinden en en güneyine
geldim bir nokta koydum çizgi çizdim
Afrika'nın en güney ucunu sonra Buradan
karşı tarafa bir çizgi çiziyorum çizdim
bakın buranın uç kesimlerini
işaretliyorum tamam mı Buradan karşı
tarafa bir çizgi çiziyorum bu köşeye
işaret Anlaştık mı Şimdi bunu siliyorum
bunu siliyorum seninle beraber Şuradaki
boş haritada bunu yapacağız şurada
Afrika'nın en kuzeyini çizdim tamam mı
takip et takip et beni etmiyorsun
görüyorum benimle beraber çiz Hadi elin
de bu kitap olmayabilir önemli değil bir
tane Harita çiz bul kitabın arkasındaki
elindeki bir kitabın arkasındaki
Haritayı aç af en kuzeyinden karşıya bir
çizgi çizdim burayı işaretledim
Afrika'nın en kuzeyinden en güneyine
indim uç kesimi işaretledim karşı tarafa
geçtim uç kesimleri işaretledim Bu
tarafa geçtim burayı işaret Anlaştık mı
tamam Şimdi Senden isteğim bu boyama
haritası hemen buraları kırmızıya
boyamanın istiyorum senden bakın şurası
ilk önce ben de boyayayım sizinle
beraber Afrika'nın en kuzeyini şöyle
Akdeniz çevresini boyadık buradan
karşıya bir çizgi çizdim köşeyi boyadım
Afrika'nın en kuzeyinden en güneyine
indim uç kesimleri bakın boyadım burada
an karşıya bir çizgi çizdim burayı boya
tamam mı Sen de benimle beraber boya bu
etkinlikle şimdi gelelim Akdeniz
iklimimiz bitirdik mi bitirdik gelelim
diğer iklimimiz Ekvatoral iklimi
Ekvatoral iklimi bulabilmenin ilk önce
Ekvator çizgisini çizmeyi öğrenmen lazım
Sen şimdi şurada Afrika var bak
Afrika'nın bir girintisi var şurada bu
girin dinin altından geçecek şekilde
çizgi çizdin işte sana ekvator çizgisi
Ekvator çizgisini bulman senin için çok
önemli çünkü ona göre diğerlerini
sıralayacak bakın ekvatorun etrafında
hemen Ekvatoral iklim var Tamam geldim
şimdi hemen boyayalım adım adım gidelim
ekvator çizgisi Afrika'nın şu girintisi
deydi buradan Ekvator çizgimi çizdim
çizdiğini varsaydım şimdi rengi
Değiştireyim ben rengimi aldım
Ekvator'un etrafındaki şu yeri boyadım
Endonezya adalarını vesaire bu bölgeyi
de boyadım diğer tarafta şu bölgeyi de
boyadım Sen de benimle beraber
boyuyorsun Evet Ekvator da tamam
Ekvator'un özellikleriyle alakal alı
konuşalım şimdi şöyle yakınlaştırdı
bakın ne diyor ekvatorun her iki yanında
0 ve 10 enlemleri arasında yani 0 10
enlemi dediği şu sıfır Ekvator kuzeyde
10 güneyde 10 kuzey ve güneyini kapsıyor
Ekvator alik diğeri bakın yağışlar
konveksiyonel şekilde düşer
konveksiyonel ne demek biliyor musunuz
az önce bir yağış çeşidini Gördük
cephesel yağışlarda Bir sıcak bir soğuk
karşılaşıyordu ama ekvatorda hava hep
sıcak e hava hep sıcaksa ısınan hava ne
yapar yükselir yükselip yağış bırakıyor
burada ısındı yükseldi yükselim yağışı
diyoruz biz buna şu konveksiyonel yanına
not al yükselim yağışı diye not almanı
istiyorum kodlamasını Nasıl yapacaksın
konveksiyonel bak konmak Kuşlar ne yapar
konabilen için yükselmeleri lazım değil
mi konveksiyonel konmak ha hocam Kuşlar
yükselip konuyordu yükselim yağışı bu
ısınan hava yükseliyor ve sürekli yağış
bırakıyor ekvator'da bunu öğrendik mi
Tamam yıl boyunca yağış Burası yani
düzenli değil mi ekvador'da sürekli
yağmur var ama yıl boyunca yağışlı
olabilir ama iki dönemi daha fazla
yağmur yağıyor ne zaman ilkbahar ve
Sonbaharda neden çünkü güneş ışınları
ilkbaharda buraya dik düştü Sonra kuzeye
gitti kuzeyde biraz uzaklaştı bakın
yağışlar yine çok fazla ama biraz
azalıyor sonra tekrar güneye geldi
Sonbaharda Sonbaharda yine Ekvator dik
düştü bakın Ne oldu ilkbaharda ve
Sonbaharda ekvatora direkt dik düştü
direkt dik düşünce Burası ısındı ve daha
fazla yağmur oldu o yüzden Ekvator her
mevsim yağmurlu Evet ama ilkbahar ve
Sonbaharda yağışlar daha fazla Anlaştık
mı Bunu da öğrendik günlük ve yıllık
sıcaklık farkı azdır yani ne demek
sıcaklıklar çok aşağı inip çıkmıyor E
öyle değil mi Ekvator sürekli sıcak gece
de sıcak O yüzden günlük sıcaklık farkı
da az yıllık da az buradaki mantık tamam
mı Tamam Akdeniz iklimini öğrendik
ekvatoru öğrendik Şimdi gelelim saran
iklime saran iklimi Hocam ne ya saran
iklimi diye bir şey mi var Ben göremedim
saran a Pardon ya yanlış mı okuyorum
yanlış okumuyor muu şum saran iklimi
değil Savan iklimi bak Savan saran bunu
bir öğrencimin kodlamasında aldım
kendisi yorumlara yazmıştı çok hoşuma
gitmişti ve ben de kullanıyorum Her
zaman da kodlamayı yaparken de o
öğrencime o öğrencimin olduğu için
söylüyorum onun yaptığını da Savan
iklimi saran iklim Savan iklimi Savan
saran Neyi sarıyor hocam Sabahtan beri
saran saran diyorsunuz Ekvator çizgisini
çizdim bakın ekvatoru saran iklim
ekvatorun bir üstünde ve bir altında
görülen iklim Savan iklimi Bakın şimdi
bunun mantığını öğrendik mi Nerede
olduğunu şuraya geliyorum Savan içinde
ne var av var değil mi av belgesellerin
çekildiği yer burası Bak belgesellerin
çekildiği yer bu gelecek aklında Savan
saran saran Savan av var hocam
belgesellerin çekildiği yer saman var
bir de orada bakın sarı Otlar 1 metreyi
bulan uzun boylu sarı Otlar var burada
zaten bu otların ismi Sava O yüzden
iklim ismini de buradan alıyor Tabii ki
bu otlar bir dönem Yeşiller bir dönem
Sarılar Nasıl yani hocam Güneş ne dedim
size ekvatora dik düştü Sonra kuzeye
gidiyor ya kuzeye gittiği zaman gençler
Güneş ışınları bakın kuzeye dik
düştüğünde E orada dik düşünce ısınacak
hava ısınıp yükselecek yağış oluşturacak
nasıl Yağmur oldu ısınan havanın
yükselmesi ile yağmur oldu değil mi
yükselim Yağmur oldu yükselim yağmuru
konveksiyonel az önce kodladım o yüzden
Savan ikliminin görüldüğü yerde de yağ
lar nasıl konveksiyonel yükselim halinde
ama şöyle bakın devam ediyorum Şimdi
burada yağmur oldu mu E haman o zaman
hocam Yağmur varsa buradaki bitkiler
yeşil midir sarı mı sarı olmaz değil mi
yeşil olur Çünkü Yağış var işte bu dönem
buradaki bitkiler Yeşiller buradaki
savanlar yeşil yani o belgesellerin
çekildiği yer bir dönem yeşil 6 ay orada
orada Güneş varken yeşil ne zaman
sararıyor E şimdi Güneş kuzeyde değil mi
Ama bakın güneydeki savanlarda Güneş
gitmiş mi gitmiş hava ısı ını böyle
yükselip Yağmur Yağ oluşturacağı
konveksiyonel yağışların olacağı bir
durum değil orada artık kuraklık var
Güneş uzak Çünkü kuzeydekiler yeşil
güneydeki sonra güneş durmuyor bakın
kuzeyde ya sonra güneye geliyor ekvatora
dik düşüyor e ekvatora dik düşünce
Burada iki dönem Ekvator yağmurlu
oluyordu mantık o bakın hepsi birbiriyle
oturuyor sonra güneye devam ediyor
güneye devam edip bu sefer güneydeki
savanlar dik düşüyor güneydeki savanlar
yeşeriyor Bu sefer kuzeydeki savanlar
sararıyor işte Savan iklimi böyle bir
dönem yağışlı bir dönem kurak iklim
yağışlı olunca savanlar yeşeriyor Sonra
sar arıyorlar mantık bu
yağışlarımdan
yükselerek oluşuyor ısınan havanın
yükselmesiyle yağış miktarı 1000100 mm
bunu
ezberlemiş Nasıl yani hocam Karadeniz'i
biliyoruz bildiğimiz bir şey de
bilmediğimiz bir şeyi somutlayıcı
500 mm Yani şöyle 1 metrekarelik alana
1000 mm 1 metre demek 1 1,5 metrelik
yağmur düşüyor Karadeniz'e Şimdi sen
Karadeniz'i Biliyorsun çok yağmurlu 1
1,5 metreymiş
somutlama bir dönem kurak olduğu için
çok ciddi orman varlığı olmuyor da yine
var orada ağaçlar Akasya ağaçları var
ama kurak dönem bütün işi bitiriyor ama
Karadeniz kadar yağmur yağıyor ama ne
zaman Yaz mevsiminde bunu da öğrendik mi
akdeniz'i öğrendik savanı öğrendik
ekvatoru öğrendik şimdi savanın nerede
olduğunu da boyayalım hemen seninle
beraber nerede ekvatoru ekvatoru saran
iklim hemen ekvatoru Savan saman
ekvatoru saran iklimde Tamam şöyle şöyle
bir de şurayı işaretleyeceğiz Burada
bakın Avustralya Avustralya'nın şu
kuzeyi gençler Aslında Savan iklimi bazı
kaynaklarda bunu Muson iklimi olarak
gösteriyor ben özellikle bu çelişkiyi
bulabilmek için Avustralya'nın kendi
iklim haritasını buldum kendi iklim
haritasında burayı Savan iklim olarak
gösteriyor ama bazı kaynaklarda Hatta
MEB'in bir kaynağında bile burayı Muson
olarak gösterdiği de var ama ben kendi
ülkesinin haritalarına baktım Burası
Muson Pardon Burası Savan iklimi zaten
Bakın aynı çizgiye denk geliyor Evet
savanı da öğrendik mi Tamam çöl iklimi
ile alakalı ne diyeceğiz çöl iklimini
biliyorduk zaten bir önceki derste
öğrendik hemen gidiyorsun altta çölü
boyuyorsun Hatta şimdi gideriz beraber
boyarız bakın tropikal çöl neydi
tropikal Çöller öğrenmiştik seninle yani
sıcak çöllerde Ekvator ve çevre Hadi ya
bir boyayı alacağım şurada Dur bir türlü
alamadım boyayı Ekvator çevresinde
oluşan dönenceler dolayı oluşan Çöller
karasal Çöller Kızıl Kara taklı atan
gobi çölleri ydi Bir de kutuplarda soğuk
Çöller vardı şunu unutmayalım bir yere
çöl dememiz için şu olması lazım yıllık
200 250 milimetrenin altında yağışı var
varsa orası çöl olarak adlandırılıyor
tamam Bakın burada ne var kurakçıl Otlar
kaktüsler var En önemlisi de sınavda
benim beklediğim kısım biraz da burası
Fiziksel çözülme var fiziksel çözülmeden
kasıt ne fiziki parçalanma olacak sabah
çok sıcak akşam soğuyor günlük sıcaklık
farkı var Burada Tamam Çöllerin yerini
biliyorsun hemen şöyle bir daha
boyayalım etkinliğimizi devam ettirelim
şurada Arizona kertenkelesi Atakan vardı
namı aklımızda kalıyordu namip kalari
Büyük Victoria Gibson çölleri
kızılkara takla atan gobi çölleri vardı
burada değil mi Şöyle Evet bunun
boyamasını da yaptık devam edelim
gelelim Muson iklimine gelelim mi haydi
bakalım değiştirdik Muson iklimi
Muson bunun kodlaması da bu kıtanın son
tarafında Mus sonlu kıtanın son
tarafında şöyle yaklaştırıyor burada
yağış nasıl oluşuyor biliyor musunuz
Muson rüzgarlarıyla oluşuyor rüzgarlar
konusunda göreceksiniz onu nasıl biliyor
musunuz basınçlarla alakalı bir durum
var 6 ay boyunca rüzgarlar buradan
denizden karaya doğru esiyorlar ve 6 ay
boyunca durmadan yağış bırakıyorlar e
Burada da Himalaya dağları var
öğrenmiştik Bir önceki derste Himalaya
dağlarına tırmanıp yağış oluyor işte
bakın dağlara tırmanıp yağış oldu
dağlara yamaca tırmanıp yağış oldu Biz
buna Yamaç yağışı diyoruz hemen Şuraya
bir not almanı istiyorum senden Yamaç
yazmanı istiyorum orografik yağış Yamaç
yaşıy dı 9 10 sınıfta kodlamış tık bunu
hatırla
ora bir da Var Uzakta bak
ora bir da var
uzakta bir daha
ora bir dağ var
uzakta orografik ora dağ Yamaç dağ
yamaçları yağışları dağ yağışları Bunlar
işte musona Himalaya dağlarında yamaç
yağışları var bakın görüyor musunuz Bir
önceki konuda öğrendiğiniz şeyler nasıl
karşınıza çıkıyor Daha ilk videoda
karşınıza çıktı Çöller karşınıza çıktı
dağ varmış orada o yüzden yağış olmuş Ne
yapıyorsun Bunlar birikimli hale geliyor
ve sen öyle bir bilgi birikimine sahip
oluyorsun ki bir süre sonra bilmediğin
bir konu hakkında bile yorum yapabilir
hale geliyorsun şimdi burada orografik
yağışlarımdan da yağış oluyor bakın o
kadar ciddi anlamda ki 2000 mm
Karadeniz'de 1 1,5 metreydi Burada 2
metre Yağmur oluyor ve bu 2 metre Yağmur
6 ayda düşüyor Yani kısa ayda daha fazla
yağmur düşüyor o yüzden ne oluyor
buralarda yazları ciddi anlamda sellerle
karşılaşıyoruz bu bölgenin diğer bir
ismi ne güneydoğu Asya kış mevsimi ne
oluyor rüzgarlar tersine dönüyor bu
sefer Karadan denize doğru gidiyor o
yüzden de yağışlar azalıyor Tamam Muson
kıtanın son tarafındaki iklim musonu da
eledik şöyle üzerlerini çize çize
gidelim mi Şöyle musonu çizdim savanı
çizdim akdeniz'i çizdim ekvatoru çizdim
çölü de öğrendik onu da çizdim şimdi
step iklimine gelelim mi step Bozkır
step Bozkır step Bozkır step Bozkır step
Bozkır step Bozkır step Bozkır step
bizim Türkiye'nin içindeki iklim
denizinden karaya doğru girmeye
başladığımızda oluşan daha yeni karasal
iklim ılıman karasal iklim daha çok
böyle Çöllerin çevresinde var bu bizim
de İç Anadolu Güneydoğu Anadolu biraz
çöle yakın değil mi biraz daha yağmasa
çöl olacak öyle düşünün Çöllerin
çevresinde dünyada bakın daha çok çölün
çevresinde göreceksiniz bunu bakın çöl
var çölün çevresinde çöl var çölün
çevresinde çöl var çölün çevresinde
görüyor musunuz çöl var çölün çevresinde
Evet step iklimi bu Bozkır step Bozkır
step Bozkır step Bozkır step Bozkır step
bitki örtüsü var burada bizim İç Anadolu
Bölgesinde yağışlar ne zaman İlkbaharda
nasıl öğreniyorduk bunu Türkiye ii bir
tane e harfi çiziyordu şöyle biraz
incelt elim şunu E harfini çiziyordu
İlkbahar yaz sonbahar kış diyorduk bakın
Türkiye'nin içinde ne var ilkbaharı var
demek ki step iklimi yağışını ne zaman
alıyormuş ilk Bahar mevsiminde alıyormuş
şuraya dikkat etmenizi istiyorum sizden
300-400 Mim Yağmur alıyor yani yıllık
250 mimin altı çöl değil miydi 250 mm
300 400 neredeyse çöle dönecek Burası
Tamam Çok ayrıntılı iklim çalışması
yapmıyoruz çok ayrıntılı iklim
çalışmasını konu anlatımını da zaten
yapacağız burada daha çok yorum yapma
yeteneğini arttıracak bir iklim
çalışması yapıyoruz ve yerlerini
öğreniyoruz Anlaştık mı step iklimini de
indirdik geldik ılıman okyanussal iklim
ılıman Okyanus ılık lık bir de okyanus
var denizle alakalı bir şey olacak bu
ülkemizdeki Karadeniz iklimine benziyor
bu gençler ülkemizdeki Karadeniz iklimi
ılıman okyanusal kodlamasını böyle getir
aklına okyanusal denizel iklim Kara
denizel iklim diyeceksin Karadeniz
iklimi bu nerede görülüyor biliyor
musunuz sıcak su akıntılarının olduğu
yerde bak ılıman okyanusal iklim ılık
Okyanus akıntılarının olduğu yerde bu
Okyanus akıntılarını şimdi bilmiyorsun
Sen bundan sonraki kamp videolarında 4
videoda ya da 5 videoda şu an
hatırlamıyorum Orada göreceksin orada
gördüğünde daha da iyi oturacak aklında
merak etme nerede var şurada Golf Stream
sıcak su akıntısı geliyor bakın şurada
Amerika'nın şu Doğu kesimini Şurada da
Avrupa kesimini ılıman
laştırma anlaştırır Karadeniz iklime
gibi sürekli yağış almasına neden oluyor
İngiltere'ye bakın Kutupta olmasına
rağmen sürekli yağmur yağıyor Normalde
kar yağması lazım neden ılıman okyanusal
iklimden dolayı yağış oluyor sıcak
oluyor şurada Alaska sıcak su akıntısı
göreceğiz bakın orayı yine ılımlaştırıcı
su akıntısı şurada Mozambik sıcak su
akıntısı şurada Doğu Avustralya sıcak su
akıntısı göreceğiz Bunların hepsi burada
ılıman okyanusal Karadeniz iklimine
neden oluyor e Hocam ben şimdi
bilmiyorum Bunları merak etme 3 4
videoda okyanusal Okyanus akıntılarını
gördüğünde bu iklimle beraber oturacak
ha Okyanus akıntısı buradaydı Bu yüzden
ılan okyanusal iklim diyeceksiniz ılan
okyanusal iklimle alakalı şunu bilmemiz
lazım karma ormanlar var var burada
Karadenizde ne var bakın Aa Burada yeni
bir kodlama çıkıyor şimdi geldi bak
baskılı söyleyince aklıma geldi
Karadenizde karma ormanlar var yani alt
kesimlerde geniş Yapraklı ağaçlar orta
kesimlerde hem geniş hem iğne üst
kesimde iğne var orta kesimde bakın hem
geniş hem iğne var karma ormanlar
Karadeniz okyanusal iklimde varmış Demek
bakın yağışı 1 1,5 metre sıcak su
akıntıların neden oluyor bunlara
okyanusal iklimi de bitirdik Geldik sert
karasal ve iklimimiz Şimdi bunu
kodlayalım seninle Türkiye'den yola
çıkacağız Tamam Türkiye'den yola
çıkacağız amacımız tam kıtanın bittiği
yere gitmek tam kıtanın bittiği yere
gitmek istiyoruz tamam mı Peki hocam
nasıl gidelim benim başta bir arabam
yoktu o zaman taylara gidelim diyoruz
Ben de size diyorum ki Ne yapalım
Arabamız yok bir şeyimiz yok Taylar la
gidelim Taylar mıza biniyoruz Bak izle
Taylar mıza biniyoruz Taylar mızda
gidiyoruz Taylar atlara b yemeyiz atlar
çok büyük Ben binmiştim Çorum'a
gittiğimde bir ata yok atlarla gitmenize
imkan yok Taylar mıza Bindik gidiyoruz
tamam tam kıtanın bittiği yere gideceğiz
amacımız kıtanın bittiği yeri görmek
kutuplara doğru gidebilmek ama kıtanın
bittiği yere gidemeden bu yerde mor olan
yere Bakın bu yerde hava çok soğuyor
etrafımızda her tarafta iğne Yapraklı
ağaçlar var gözünü aç Görsel kodlama
yapıyoruz Bak her tarafta iğne Yapraklı
ağaçlar var artık gidemeyeceğiz üşüdük
inelim şu atlar Taylan Pardon at dedim
Taylan inelim bu tayları çam ağaçlarına
bağlayalım Taylar orada dursun Biz bir
ateş yakalım Isınalım bak ateş yakıp
ısınıyoruz Ateş yakıp ısındık oh tamam
dedik tamam mı Şöyle Oh be Tamam dedik
Taylar mız donmuş bir bakıyoruz Taylar
mız donmuş artık taylara gitmemize imkan
yok taylara gidemeyiz artık çam
ağaçlarına bağladık da Taylar mızı çam
ağaçlarına bağladık ya işte o iğne
yapraklı çam ağaçlarına bağladık onların
ismi Tayga ormanları Şuraya bak kalemim
nereye gitti ya Şuraya Nerede bu ha sert
karasal bakın şurada Tayga ormanları
Taylar mızı bağladık ısındık Şimdi yola
çıkacağız ama Taylar mız yok nasıl
gideceğiz Ah Be Hiç merak etmeyin Artık
eskisi gibi değil Yunus hoca tundra
aracını aldı şöyle koyayım şuraya Bu
benim tundra aracım ismini aracın ismini
tundra koyduk Bu arada gerçekten aracın
ismi tundra tundra la gideceğiz artık
hiç merak etmeyin diyorum size hiç merak
etmeyin bundan sonra taylara uğraşmanıza
gerek yok tundra la gideceğiz tundra la
nereye gidiyoruz kıtanın tam bittiği
yere gidiyoruz gidiyoruz gidiyoruz
gidiyoruz ama bir şey var çok kötü
tundra araç araçta sorun yok araçtan bir
iniyoruz a ayaklarımız kunduralarım
bataklığa batıyor kunduralarım bataklığa
batıyor burada tundra kundra tundra
dediğinde birisi bize kunduralarım
bataklığa batıyordu diyeceksin aynı
zamanda tundra aracı da aklına gelecek
tam kıtanın bittiği yere gitmiştik
tundur aracımla beraber Burası bataklık
Topraklar Yılın 9 ayı donmuş halde
Burası 3 ay hafiften çözünüyor çözününce
de altı donmuş üstteki hafif çözününce
alta gidemiyor zaten orada bataklık
oluşturuyor burada gençler yosunlar ve
likenler var bakın bir üstü kıtanın tam
bittiği yere gittik şurası sert Karas
saldı kıtanın tam bittiği yer artık
tundra iklimi burada yosunlar ve çalılar
var ve Burası batak Tamam sert karasal
iklim Tayga ağaçlarımız vardı burada
Taylar mızı bağlamıştı Şurada da kıtanın
tam bittiği yerde de tundra aracımızla
gitmiştik kunduralarım batak batmış
Tamam Burada da Kutup iklimimiz var
gençler şuna dikkat etmenizi istiyorum
sizden bakın tam kıtanın bittiği yer
tundra bakın tam kıtanın bittiği yer
tundra Bu arada 2 sene önce direkt bunu
sordular kıtanın bittiği yere işaret
koyup tundra yı sordular direkt sınav
sorusuyla Grönland adasında bu sefer
kıtanın başladığı yer tundra iç
kesimlerine gidince Kutup iklimiyle
karşılaşıyoruz burada bitki örtüsü yok
ve yılın 12 ay boyunca sıcaklar 0
derecenin altında Tamam iklimler izi
öğrendik mi iklimlerin haritası burada
bakın burada dolu olduğu için bilgiler
harita tam net değil buraya o yüzden bir
tane harita koyduk Bu haritaya bakarak
hemen burada kalan iklimleri boyama
etkinliği yapıyorsun Tamam hemen hızlı
bir şekilde etkinliğini yap Buraya da
gel seninle beraber pekiştirme
etkinliğimizi yapalım yeşil olan koyu
yeşil Ekvator çizgimi çizdim Ekvatoral
iklim Ekvatoral iklim Ben gençler
yazarken araları kesiyorum zaman
kaybetmeyelim diye tamam şurada Biraz
daha açık kapalı sarı olan ya açık sarı
artık neyse sarı olmayan tam sarı gibi
olacak olan saran iklim ekvatoru sarıyor
bakın saran iklimi yani Savan iklimi
Şuradaki yeşil olan Mus son iklimi
kıtanın sonu kıtanın son tarafına doğru
Mus son sarı olan çöl bakın çöllerim
kırmızı olan Akdeniz iklimi köşelere
gidiyorduk uçlara Akdeniz Akdeniz mavi
olan şurada sıcak su akıntımı geliyordu
okyanusal iklime neden oluyordu ılıman
okyanusal mor olan sert karasal kıtanın
iyice içi sert karasal turuncu olan
çölün çevresi step Bozkır step bakın
şurada gri olan tam kıtanın bittiği yer
tunda kunduralarım batmıştı benim tunda
aracım beyaz olan da Kutup ik bunu da
yap Evet ne yaptın şimdi sen dünyadaki
makr klima iklimlerin nerede olduğunu
hangi çizgilerde nasıl kodlamalarla
öğrenildiğini hangi iklimlerin hangi
özelliklere sahip olduğunu çok güzel bir
şekilde öğrendik geldin artık senin
temelin süper bak artık senin temelin
Süper Gel seninle bunun bir ipucusu
yapalım mı şeyini mesela bakın verilen
iklim türlerinden sıcak kuşak
iklimlerinde hangileridir bir tane örnek
bakıyorum şimdi sıcaklık 0 derece burada
sıcaklık çok yüksek öyle çok da inmemiş
bakın 20 derece civarında Demek ki bu
sıcak iklimlerde Tamam yağışına
bakıyorum şimdi ya hiç de yağmur
yağmamış işte 30 desek şunları toplasak
100 110 falan 110 mm Eğer bir yerde
yağış miktarı 200 250 mimin altındaysa
Biz ona Ne diyorduk çöl diyorduk Demek
ki burası çöl ikliminin grafiği Tamam
gelelim buraya
A burada bir yüksek sıcaklık var Tamam
sıcaklık yüksek O zaman bu sıcak
iklimlerden Ekvator ve çevresinde olacak
Ekvator olabilir mi olamaz ekvator'da
sürekli yağmur vardı burada burada
sadece Yaz mevsiminde yağmur var demek
ki bu ya Muson ya Savan ama nasıl
ayırmıştı savanla musonu hocam Muson
biraz daha kuzeye gidiyordu biraz daha
bir tık daha ve orada sıcaklar biraz
daha böyle 20 20'nin altına düşüyordu
musona ve musona şu kadar bir kuraklık
yoktu burada direkt bir kuraklık olmuş
ve sıcaklar ekvatordaki kadar yüksek
Demek ki burası ekvatoru saran iklim
Savan iklimi diyorsun bak grafiği böyle
okuyorsun buna bakıyorum ya sıcaklığa
bakıyorum 20 derecenin altına hiç
düşmemiş sıcaklık hep yüksek ve böyle
çok zikzak da çizmemi hep yüksek o zaman
ya aşlar da hep yüksek e her mevsim
Yağmur olan Her Mevsim sıcak olan yer
Ekvator iklimi değil mi Ekvatoral iklim
çok güzel buna bakıyorum hocam sıcaklık
bak 20'nin biraz altına inmiş öyle Çok
da fazla inmemiş Ama yine biraz inmiş he
Ama hala sıcak Yaz mevsiminde almış
yağmurunu yaz Mus sonlarıyla ve mutlak
bir kuraklık olmadığı için bu Muson mu
Savan mı desem Hocam bu Muson o zaman
bakın savanla musonu da ayırabilen bak o
dersi iyi dinlediğini düşünüyorum şuna
bakalım ben sana ne dedim köşelerde
yağış köşelerde yağış karstik Akdeniz
kızılçam Maki Çalık kış cephe karstik
Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalı kış kış
mevsiminde yağmurunu alan bakın Aralık
Ocak Şubat köşeleri gördün mü kış
mevsimi dedin mi Akdeniz diyeceksin Şuna
bak - 20'lere inmiş sıcaklık 0 derecenin
üzerine 23 ay çıkabilmiş Yılın 9 ayı
donmuş şurada 3 ayı hafiften çözülmüş
bataklık tundur larımızın battığı kundra
iklimi şuna bakıyorum hocam - 60'lara
gitmiş 0 derecenin üzerine sıcaklık hiç
çıkmamış Burası Kutup iklimi bakın ne
yaptık bütün iklimlerin grafikleri ile
beraber özelliklerini öğrendik Eğer ki
sen şimdi o iklimleri böyle adam gibi
öğrendiysen artık Kimse sana sıkıntı
çıkartamaz grafik yorumlamayı da
biliyorsun Şimdi gelelim Türkiye'deki
iklim türlerine Şimdi sen dünyadaki
Makro klima iklimleri bildiğin için
türkiye'dekiler bilmek daha kolay
gelecek sana Bakın bu Türkiye'deki
görülen iklimler Karanın içinde Gençler
biz karasal iklim görürüz şu taraftaki
karasal iklimler biraz daha ılıman
karasaldır biraz daha ılımandır çok
soğuk değildir -5 lere kadar düşer 0a
0'ın altına yeni yeni düşer buradaki
sıcaklık grafiğindeki düşüşler Doğu
Anadolu'ya gittiğimizde şuralara bakın
mor olan yerler bunlar sert karasal
iklimdir burada -10 L eki 20'ler görülür
Ben şimdi Kars Ard dağına gittiğimde -20
için aracı hazırlamaya çalışıyorum Şu an
mesela dizelle ısınıyorum dizel
donuyormu galiba - 25'de falan mesela
donmaması için farklı dizel alacağım
orada Burası sert karasal iklim bakın
şurası ılıman karasal iklim şu sarı olan
yer şu Karadenizin olduğu yer Karadeniz
iklimi Karadeniz iklimi busan Az önce
gördüğün iklimlerdeki ılıman okyanusal
iklime benziyor okyanusal Karadeniz
şurası da Karadeniz'in arkasındaki de
bakın geç iklimi var demiştik ya burası
Karadeniz geçiş iklimi Karadeniz geçiş
iklimi Akdeniz iklimi bakın Akdeniz
karstik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki Çalı kış
kış mevsiminde yağmurunu alır yağışlar
cephe şeklindedir bakın akdeniz'le
karasal arasındaki bir geçiş iklimi var
Akdeniz karasal Bu arada bir geçiş lazım
bize bu da Akdeniz'den karasal geçiş
iklimi bakın yine aynı burada burada da
geçiş iklimi var Marmara şurası da
Akdeniz'den Karadeniz de geçiş iklimi
Burası da geçiş iklimi Burası da geçiş
iklimi makroklima iklimleri öğrendik ya
orada öğrendiğimiz bilgileri getirip bu
Türkiye'de uygulayacaksın Ilıman
okyanusal iklimi Karadeniz iklimine
uyarladı Akdeniz iklimini bakın şurada
Akdeniz'e uyarladı Akdeniz'de gördüğün
bilgiler burada geçerli Tamam Türkiye'de
görülen iklim haritamız bu bunlarla
alakalı soru çözeceğiz O soruları
kesinlikle dinle Hatta Google'a
Türkiye'de Türkiye iklimi soru çözümü
yaz coğrafyanın kodları karşına bir sürü
video çıkar hepsini izle tamam Bakın
Kars Antalya Rize bunlarla alakalı hangi
iklime ait olduğuyla alakalı bir
etkinlik yapalım karasal Karadeniz
Akdeniz köşelerde kışın yağmuru gördüm
hocam burası o zaman Akdeniz ikli mi
diyeceksin karsik Akdeniz kızılçam Maki
Çalı kış o zaman Burası ne bu Antal A
bak Antalya zaten vermiş O zaman bu
hangi iklim Akdeniz iklimi akdiz buraya
geldim E hocam Burada hemen hemen her
mevsim yağmur var ve en fazla yağmurunu
Sonbaharda almış ben sana bir ipucu
göstermiştim Bak bu grafikleri böyle
kendin bulabilirsin ne demiştim sana
Türkiye'yi çizecek en fazla yağmurunu
alma kısmında şöyle bir e harfi
yazacaktın ilkbahar yaz Karadeniz
sonbahar Akdeniz kıştı değil mi Bakın
şimdi en fazla yağmurunun ne zaman almış
Eylül Ekim Kasım ne zaman bu sonbaharda
e en fazla yağmurunu Sonbaharda alan yer
neresidir karadeniz'dir zaten buraya da
Rize yazmış o zaman bu hangi iklim kara
Deniz iklimi buraya geliyorum bak
sıcaklıklar 0 dereceye yaklaşmış şurada
0 derecenin de biraz altına inmiş
Karanın içine yeni girmiş demek ılıman
karasal var burada başka nereden
anlayabilirim bunu Ocak Şubat bak mart
nisan mayıs en fazla yağmurunu
ilkbaharda almış En fazla yağmurunu
ilkbaharda neresi alır İç Anadolu kısmı
iç kısımlar ılıman karasal iklim Demek
ki burası ılıman karasal buraya
geliyorum bakın eksi 0'ın altına bakın
ek5 -10 vara inmiş ve en fazla yağmurunu
Mart Pardon mart nisan mayıs haziran bak
mayıs haziran Temmuz'a kayıyor
ilkbaharın sonu Yazın başı baharın sonu
yazında almış ama ve eksi 10'lara kadar
gitmiş sıcaklık o zaman burası sert
karasal diyeceksin tamam Bakın ÖSYM
çıkmış sorusu bütün Az önce
anlattıklarımın doğrultusunda bu soruyu
çözebilecek misin bakalım bu soruyu
çözebiliyor Tamamdır sınavda yaparsın
dikkat etmeni istediğim nokta şurası Ben
çözmüyor bunu ÖSYM sorusu sıfırın altına
biraz düşmüş bak birazcık düşmüş sıfırın
altına mart nisan mayıs ilkbaharda en
fazla yağmurunu almış ona göre buradaki
seçenekleri gruplandır Tamam Evet
iklimle alakalı kısmı bitirdik Bir
sonraki videoda soru çözüm olacak
kesinlikle soru çözüm videosunu
izliyorsun bu konunun soru çözümünü
izlemeden derse coğrafya dersine devam
etmek yok hemen bu videodan sonra bir
saat sonra gelecek olan soru çözüm
videosuyla pekiştiriyor
bu konuyu da bitirdik geçelim artık bu
dersin 17 videosuna diyoruz ne diyoruz o
zaman Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir
daha asla unutma zeda ile eğitim her
yerde